en el primer día de alto el fuego entre
hamás e israel la calma se mantiene se
mantiene pero tensa y el consenso es que
es una frágil tregua que cualquier
movimiento demasiado violento en
cisjordania en gaza o en jerusalén este
podría echar a perder esta situación por
el otro lado el primer ministro israelí
benyamín netanyahu ha dicho que los
éxitos militares israelíes sobre hamas
en gaza y la jihad islámica son más
importantes de lo que se cree o lo que
el público sabe porque todavía no han
divulgado todos los detalles sin embargo
un jefe militar en condición de
anonimato ada ha rebatido estas palabras
de netanyahu y ha dicho que los éxitos
del ejército israelí frente a hamás han
sido menores de los esperados por su
parte y haya si no hay jefe de hamas ha
dicho que el gran logro de su
organización ha sido que ha desbaratado
los planes de pacificación y de
normalización de relaciones entre israel
y los países del golfo y otros estados
árabes